now for some reason john lynch the gm of
the 49ers and i respect john but he's
too candid he's too honest to be a gm in
the nfl because you can't come out and
say the night that you picked trey lance
john come on i know that i don't know
who's running their pr there now i'm not
sure anyone is you can't come out the
night that you pick trey lance and
acknowledge that you called the packers
about aaron rodgers and just say well
you know he's the mvp of the league
would you expect no no you can't do you
can't undermine the the move for trey
lance and acknowledge that you did it
you can't let's hear what john lynch had
to say so we can properly scrutinize it
i don't want to be unfair to john i like
john lynch but let's hear what he said
you're talking about um you know the mvp
of our league last year and uh i don't
know about you guys but to me when the
mvp of the league might be available and
i didn't know that um i'm just reading
the tea leaves just like everybody else
and saying hold on is something going on
here
um you know
yeah we inquired and uh it was a it was
a quick uh into the conversation it
wasn't happening and uh
you know as we've said we've been
convicted and excited for a long long
time so
um we went right back to where we've
been and that's really excited about
adding trey lance to the 49ers and and
we're thrilled about that
i appreciate the candor i appreciate it
very much i just don't know why you
admit that because
it wasn't just curiosity it wasn't just
due diligence it was you know what you
know what there may be something here
guys hang on before before we use this
third overall pick on someone who's
unproven
maybe there's a way that we can get
aaron rodgers let's see if there's a way
that we can get the packers attention
let's see if we can do this that would
have been seismic because
that's another example of how tom brady
has broken the brains of teams in the
nfl you've got an organization that
would be willing to trade the
opportunity to get a guy who could be
their quarterback for 15 years for a guy
who's going to come in for three or four
years
it's it's it this is a it's russell
wilson it's aaron rodgers and it's the
mindset we're going to go all in now
forget about building for the future
we'll go all in right now with a guy
that we think is going to deliver
multiple championships before he retires
yeah and they were they were they would
have done it this wasn't let's just
let's just see so we know what we're
we're getting and what we're actually
doing with our pick tonight hell no if
they just said yes they'd have done it
chris a hundred people said they should
have a hundred percent
a hundred percent because yeah maybe a
15-year career in a franchise
quarterback maybe
it's an iffy very very risky reward
pick and trey lance every i don't think
a lot of people would really disagree
with that statement it's a risk reward
it's a boomer bus prospect so you have
that for wait we could have aaron
rodgers for three or four years at
playing at top five quarterback level i
think you take that you know mike like
it was already out there by the time the
press conference had happened about the
49ers the packers thing i think the
right we're not talking about we're not
talking about anybody who's under
contract with another team that's all he
had to say i'm not talking about anybody
who's under contract with another team
and then it's okay but then it's just
it's a but then there's just all there
is a speculation and it continues to
talk and talk and talk to me he ends up
there he ends it there and
he undermines trey lance he undermined
traders
trey lance knows what he's dealing with
wait oh you guys thought about aaron
rodgers oh how dare you thought about
getting the greatest quarterback of all
time on your team he's a big boy he'll
get it first test can you take a little
nfl scrutiny he'll be fine i i can't
blame the 49ers for calling the packers
when there's rogers rumors out there and
then there's a relationship with the
head coach of the packers and the head
coach of the 49ers for calling to see
hey
um is he for sale i'm not going to blame
them for that that that
let me just say this let me say this
there's another reason to say we're not
going to talk about players under
contract with other teams because
there's a rule that basically says you
can't and he may have said enough last
night if the nfl actually cared about
the tampering rule that's on the books
that only gets
enforced arbitrarily whenever they feel
like they want to go whack someone
because so many teams violate
he he he kind of did he kind of did what
part but well he made it clear that
there was an interest they're interested
in a player who's under contract with
another team they are they acknowledge
publicly their interest in a player
who's under contract with another team
that is a textbook violation of the
tampering rules and the only thing
that's going to save the 49ers is the
nfl doesn't care about their own rules
well what do you mean there's and i mean
you're allowed to call teams and you're
not you're not allowed to say it
publicly chris i can read the rule for
you you're not allowed to publicly
express interest in a player who's under
contract with another team which is what
they did i don't want to get too far
into the weeds my point is i would have
advised strongly before that press
conference begins anybody asked about
aaron rodgers we're not going to talk
about players under contract with other
teams that's a violation of the
tampering rules then you don't you don't
have to get into it you can focus on
we're here tonight to talk about trey
lance this guy's our future this is the
guy we wanted we're not talking about
anybody else we can't talk about anybody
else we're talking about him that's just
i just think that that that would have
been a better way to go
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports